your first one was tropical kiss oh yeah
and this was like
okay i'm glad you started off with this
one because this like
this one epitomized everything i love
about wholesome vanilla hentai
where it's just like this this one this
not gonna lie like you have that whole
[ __ ] build up from like start to fit
you know granted it's not like an anime
episode level of build up right like
yeah
it's a generic in what world was this
wholesome
which i mean like drunk [ __ ] raped
like that girl
and then he's like oh but no i love you
and it's like which one is it okay okay
i
i i i actually i asked you because like
how could you sit there and be like yeah
he drunk
[ __ ] and then it
and then you're gonna say it's awesome
no no because it's it's wholesome
vanilla but it has like this little bit
of spice in there
because so like well
that's okay okay okay like that's like a
typical spice in [ __ ] hentai let's
yeah but it what i put this in is kind
of like it run
it really reminded me of something like
rumbling hearts um if you guys think
rumbling hearts
it's like it's like a really mellow
dramatic anime
so should we describe what happens in
this hentai photo sure you don't know
sure joey i mean you chose it so i
thought you were the best not gonna lie
i
haven't seen in a while okay uh so maybe
one of you boys should explain how it
happens okay so from what i remember
there are like two main girls right
and i okay so i wasn't playing
it starts off right i remember this
because i literally wrote this i'm like
it's i'm 11 minutes in
and nothing is [ __ ] happening when
will something happen
that's typical so this is it's about
like they all work at a resort it's not
really
told but then they are working there
it's like a pool yeah
indoor pool resort we're not told why
all these six girls want to [ __ ] this
guy right because there seems to be
nothing redeemable about him right but
there's like
almost like six or seven girls two of
them are identical so i was so [ __ ]
confused half the time so i'm like yeah
why is there two
[ __ ] pink girls the exact same but
it's like a different tint of pink right
no no and then and then the first scene
is like her being like yeah i don't want
to be with you anymore yeah
and then literally two minutes later
after another girl showed interest she's
like wait i love you
can we take it back but and then he
reveals like he like had
took like had drunk sex with the blue
head girl yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was
really weird
yeah so like the second episode i
remember the second or third episode i
forgot which one awesome
is the blue head girl this is what i
hated because
this episode they build up what is
supposed to be as god says a wholesome
relationship between him and this
this pink head girl yeah in the back of
your head you're like they've shown a
harem and a hentai yeah
so you know he's gonna have his fill and
every girl here yeah so how does this
this this story remain wholesome
when i know the next episode he's gonna
have the exact same [ __ ] with another
because the route
this is the one this is the one route
and also it's it's
all it's all in the same universe isn't
it it's all the same [ __ ] like it's a
different route
but like yes it's i mean it's it's
different route but at the same time
it's like a developing story that
something similar to
i mean i said ramming hearts but like
more recent example would be like
domestic girlfriend you know where they
have like relationships
but like he jumps between relationships
and it's like it has
it has a little bit of like spice and
context to their relationship which is
which i appreciate that which i
appreciate so they like speed run
introduce characters
in the first like two minutes yeah and
i'm like i'm trying to [ __ ] write i
was literally trying to write this [ __ ]
down and i couldn't keep up because
yeah so then there would be like six
dramatic scenes back to back that felt
like i needed a whole episode before it
to understand what the [ __ ] was going on
because i'm like wait wait what he loves
this girl but then there's this other
girl and then there's another girl
and then the two hottest girls we don't
even get an episode with oh yeah yeah
because i watched all of it right and i
was like fine
this is why you watched all three no i
went to right because i was like you
know what let's see what the other
episode
episodes are i want to see if they have
the the best girls yeah yeah the two hot
ones
right because those girls weren't that
hot because i'm not interested
in the [ __ ] lolly skip that episode
delete that episode
if i'm concerned it only doesn't get
[ __ ] though yeah yeah she does
right who's the lolly which one's
there's two lollies which one which is
too many
ways are we watching the same shot oh
yeah yeah there's a blue headlight
and then she's not always he's not a
volleyball he's basically a lolly
no what are you talking about she looks
like twelve come on the [ __ ] what are
you talking about you get a picture of
this [ __ ]
you get a picture of me i've never just
thrown my teeth she is just like
a stereotypical [ __ ] just she's just
a normal girl how is this lolly how is
this lolly
in your like eyes is it cause like she
has like average boob size your standard
of lolly's whack
yeah yeah i remember just because she
has normal sized teeth it's like
tropical kiss right yeah but then
there's the brown haired one right who
you don't even [ __ ] see on screen
the brown head one there's literally a
brown head lolly who appears for like
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not gonna i don't
know pixar didn't happen
because i remember there was one lolly
which was the actual lolly in that and
she's like just not involved yeah in any
of the scenes
but the blue head girl is not like no no
that's from the [ __ ] visual novel
that's also not a lolly you know if you
look from the [ __ ]
okay look you know what move on put up
too close for coming put up a picture of
the blue head girl oh yeah right and put
a picture of the pink hat girl yeah who
connor is calling lollies no the pink
head one isn't a lolly
brown head girl who's 100 likes no brown
hair the brown hair goes yes the blue
pig
it's just like stereotypical anime girl
number one
the plot was [ __ ] garbage like it's
like
if i'm gonna watch a porn and there's
trying to sell me on plot
which i don't appreciate in the first
place right like you better make it skip
the story yeah you better make it good
right because there are
decent hentai plots out there right like
one like what well we'll we'll talk
about it
we'll talk about connors no because what
i liked about this one is that it did
have a plot that i could appreciate
because appreciating much sense huh in
what sense could you appreciate it
because it it felt like it was yes it
was speed running
like space it was speed running
basically a romance dramatic drama
animal yeah
that that that was it that was basically
this hentai you can't tell me that like
the the final like [ __ ]
speed run of like sex isn't hot i mean
oh yeah that okay that was good but then
as well at the same time when they were
speed running i'm like yo slow down
these scenes are great
they're skipping all the best parts man
like
if i'm watching a trailer on brass yeah
they give me 11 minutes of character
development and then a 30-second
compilation of sexiest
are you for real like what are you
trying to do to me here the fact is
it had [ __ ] character development
yeah exactly because this
like it's basically watching like
something like golden time or something
right except the characters actually
yeah
it was love island with just one mayor
that's like that's what it was like it
was
they were just all like [ __ ] rotating
and [ __ ] and then like
all the other girls had no [ __ ]
personality you didn't like like the
character designs or anything yeah okay
the animation was really good yeah
animation is great this the second one
i was surprised how good the animation
was for like 2012 [ __ ] 12.
yeah i remember actually i think i
commented saying like yeah the the
[ __ ] seems good
i i don't like [ __ ] scenes so i
thought that was good did you actually
like
[ __ ] review each section individually
because i didn't even go that far
blow job good i said i said god this is
legit shitty school days
because there's like they were like
playing up the drama between two
characters but yo yo yo like like
let's not [ __ ] around school days is a
good hentai it's a bad anime yeah that's
a good idea it's a good hentai it's a
good [ __ ] anime i mean i mean it's
that no it's a good environment
was that a freudian anyway
because the thing is when i watched the
school day anime it felt like i'm
watching a hentai plot without the hint
of yeah so
what it what would it be like if i
watched the hentai and it's a hentai
well it's just a good hentai
yeah exactly another scene that i wasn't
i thought was the [ __ ] is the point in
this
they all meet in the onsen to discuss
who's gonna [ __ ] him
like just as you do because you need
some you need some spice do you i don't
need that
i need some [ __ ] because the girls
need to compete with each other yeah
and as we know but they don't want to
hurt each other's feelings
i'm going to get [ __ ] for this do you
not like a little bit of realism in your
in your porn like a little bit of ooh
that could be me
i mean what do you mean because let's be
honest
five women who are all polygamous and
all want to [ __ ] me and are totally okay
with competing for that fact
i i stress that that goes a little too
far on my mind but isn't that the point
of like
self-inserting media yeah but then like
if in my head it's got to be like
somewhat tangible like that could maybe
happen in a faraway land right
but that like come on come on yeah i
mean like for me with hensel
i mean i would say yeah this this was
like unrealistic like the harem aspect
at least
it was like unrealistic where you know
he needed to get with a different girl
because less because it was realistic
and more because you're watching a
hentai yeah yeah right
and i guess my mind has just gotten used
to like
shutting off the unrealistic past and be
like you know
i'm watching a hentai that's what's hot
when you can be like that could be me
yeah but i also have god i wish that was
me
but i also utilize just like my vivid
imagination
i mean i mean like i closed that part
i enjoyed the relationship like
development aspect
of this hentai yeah um i would i will
actually agree with you where i was just
like yeah
i do wish there was like less girls
involved put
three three and let them all like
because there was only three episodes as
well and if these [ __ ] knew
they were on a budget they should have
done three episodes with three
characters yeah
because they left out like the two
hottest girls yeah because in this kind
of hair in this
type of hentai that i would like to
recommend i i reckon like
the the optimal amount is two girls two
girls like
like having a gentleman's agreement to
like have have like a relationship with
this guy
already already unrealistic
i don't know man i just like to be
spoiled for choice you know like but
there's nothing wrong with the [ __ ]
brothel i just i just like to be small
but like if it's like
i don't know i think the one aspect i
like about like a lot of harem hentai is
that
we will we'll get to that with your
second channel because like
the thing i like about harem hentai is
because it's unrealistic right yeah so
like i don't have to think like oh that
could be me
i could just [ __ ] use my imagination
i and also i don't have to like
self-insert myself into harrowing yeah
right i'd just be like that's what's hot
though right like
and also you know i mean it's a bit it's
a bit of everything
when it's like five girls it's way too
unrealistic like god [ __ ]
how much am i gonna have to not to like
keep this up this is insane like i mean
let's be real every like
anti-protagonist has like maybe when i
was like 15 i could i could [ __ ] like
yeah but like now my gosh the logistics
of the amount of protein shakes
okay
i was gonna say this during like the
second one you mentioned but if we're
talking about this already yeah i'm like
if we're going haram right three is the
[ __ ] maximum right right
three is gonna make sure we save it
for the second one but yeah like i mean
if i would recommend like a nice
wholesome
like hentai with like that that i liked
that i was going to recommend if i
didn't say this
but i don't remember the name liliana
i've seen it and i don't even [ __ ]
i don't know how to [ __ ] pronounce
this hold on yeah so my overall review
of it was would be hotter if there
wasn't
four hotter girls in it six out of ten
hey that's still possible because the
the scenes like the animation was
[ __ ] killer yeah the animation is
[ __ ] great but they skipped over all
the best bits yeah so it's like what's
the point
watch read that uh because i'm reading a
[ __ ] porn joey
if i were to recommend a hentai that if
you only want one person and you have
the same kind of relationship
development
uh wagiano lilianasan um which is
which is a hentai that came out recently
and it's just pure wholesome
like two people meets and they some of
the tongue girl
no no it's it's the one with like the
dark skinned girl and
they go they go on like a date i've seen
like every recent time
you've probably seen this one you've
probably seen this one yeah and that one
do you want the top hat
i've watched like every hentai in the
past like three years that's come out
yeah
and you'd have me anyway only like
[ __ ] what like five come out of like
a month yeah
it's true it's manageable this is what
there's charts and everything they tell
you when they come out yeah like i keep
up man